It's the e-cig apocalypse!
And I'm gonna be real -- I have a very bad
feeling about it, right in here.
Hello friends, Laci Green here for DNews.
Is it me or was it practically overnight that
it went from people smoking cigarettes to
sucking on those little tubes that look like
ink pens?
In the past couple years, electronic cigarettes
have shot up to a multi billion dollar industry.
It happened so fast, government officials
are like AHHHHHH WHAT IS THIS WIZARDRY AND
HOW DO WE REGULATE IT?
Meanwhile, minors can buy e-cigs legally in
many states, they're being given away as free
samples online, and the companies are actively
marketing themselves as a "tobacco free alternative
to cigarettes" that will "help you quit".
OKKKKK.
This is my skeptical face, guys.
While all the legal junk is worked out, it's
up to SCIENTISTS to take a good hard look
at these newfangled devices.
Last week, the largest major review of the
research on e-cigs was published in the American
Heart Association's scientific journal.
They found that the claims of the e-cig manufacturers
are...not supported by the data.
One of the big claims that came under fire
was that e-cigs will help you quit...or at
least smoke less.
The scientists found, based on 5 population-based
studies, that those who used e-cigs to quit
were actually significantly LESS likely to
be successful, by about 30%.
And that's probably related to....claim #2
that was kicked to the curb: that it's a safe
alternative that only releases pure nicotine
and water vapor.
In their research, the scientists found formaldehyde,
propylene glycol, and lead amongst other well-known
toxins in the vapor.
Sound familiar?
It's just...like...cigarettes!
UC San Francisco's tobacco research center
stated that "E-cigs do not deliver pure nicotine
and harmless water vapor".
It may not have tobacco in it, but the e-cigs
are still delivering the same carcinogens
that are known to cause chronic disease and
cancer.
And the second hand vapor is emitting it as
well.
Then there's there's the most disturbing part
of the study to ME.
A growing number of middle and high schoolers
report having tried e-cigs instead of cigarettes,
and the number of teen users more than doubled
to almost 2 million from 2011 to 2012.
It's even more now in 2014, which is a concern
given that 90% of lifetime nicotine addiction
begins in the teen years.
The e-cig industry seems to be intentionally
targeting teens--they use cool marketing with
colors and candy flavors, they sponsor youth-driven
events like rock concerts all the while claiming
that they're harmless.
Some teens in the studies didn't even know
that it contains nicotine, even though they
may be able to buy them.
Let's be real: this industry's goal is to
sell a product and develop lifelong buyers,
and if they are allowed to sell addictive
substances with misleading claims, then they
will....and personally, I don't think they
should be able to.
But I want to know what you guys think.
Tell me your thoughts about e-cigs down below
and I'll catch you next time on DNews!